we have our own provider right here in
the usa it's called the new york times
and check out this headline from the new
york times this week here's a doozy the
rise of the far right latina
representative myra flores is one of
three republican latinas vying to
transform south texas politics by
shunning moderates and often embracing
the extreme now of course myra flores
won her district about two weeks ago it
had been under democrat control for
about a hundred years it was mostly
about the border so of course now she's
far right uh sarah we've got a special
lower third for you you are our far
right latina expert today
uh but first let's show a little video
of uh myra flores responding to this
nonsense
with that far left bias the new york
times has
should you and i consider the new york
times a legitimate news organization
congresswoman
they're not like i said they don't know
us they have no idea who we are and who
our culture you know
they just do not represent our community
and i feel that you know no one really
cares about the new york times
especially in my district we're worried
about health care we're worried about
the cost of gas the cost of food that's
what we're worried about not the new
york times or none this nonsense that's
happening in washington latinx none of
that we're focused on the issues that
really matter to
to the american people and i refuse to
you know give them any attention they
claim that they're for immigrants i'm an
immigrant i'm from mexico and yet all
they do is hate me
all right gonzalez
gonzalez far-right latina expert
do you agree with flores
oh 100 i mean look i have been saying
for years now that the democrats
would
they would experience a
high levels of loss of hispanic voters
because
as always they overplay their hand they
want to make it all about illegal
immigrants as myra pointed out
they they claim to be for immigrants but
only the ones who have gotten here uh
illegally so what that does it slaps in
the face to all of the people who did it
the right way who know that there is a
legal process and who respect this
country enough to go through that legal
process she also said you know on top of
the border uh her issues are god family
and country these are things that
traditional hispanic families value very
very highly a lot you know most of them
are catholic uh they are very very
pro-life they are very very staunch in a
lot of these social issues that
democrats have just gone so far left and
so far extreme that hispanics are like
i thought i was with you guys but it
turns out now that you've shown your
true colors i actually don't think i
align with you guys anymore i've said
that it was going to happen for years i
think that it took being under the
leadership of trump for them to realize
how well they had it you know they were
working the economy was good the things
that actually matter to these hispanic
families they were all good they saw
that happen then they see the switch to
joe biden and they saw all of the
extremes that they were going to the
left was and how it did not align with
their traditional family values and i
think hispanics have really had enough i
hope that that's what we see in november
um i really do dave isn't there
something kind of beautiful about this
because they're showing us exactly what
they did to trump and how they'll do it
to any of us to call her far right then
if you read the article and i i actually
read a new york times article i mean
basically all they say as you reference
the the far what they mean by far right
is that she's for a border unless she
goes to church that's what they meant by
far right so it's sort of like oh
remember when they used to do that to
trump and he he wasn't even a big
church-goer nick i surprise i guess none
of this is surprising to you like you've
seen this game before yeah
well when uh you know she says that her
slogan is god family and country god and
family are the first things the leftists
want to get rid of because that the only
thing they want is country they don't
want god or family because those things
make your allegiance to someone other
than the state
and so this is
this is not an accident that they're
going after her uh because she is a
turncoat to them she they think they
have these ethnic tribes that are
supposed to be democrat and anybody that
turns against them and goes the other
way is now the enemy and to call her far
right
common sense is far right
to to today's left it's like she wants
to have a border where you can control
who comes in and out well that's any
everybody should want that that's common
sense you don't leave your door unlocked
in case somebody wants to come in your
house and get something you want to
control who comes in and out of your
house i wonder if they're going to leave
the gates open at their gated community
and just say it's it's really
discriminatory for us to keep people out
of our gated communities we need to open
the gates no they're not going to do
that
by the way i don't want to brag but it
was about five years ago that front page
sunday new york times called me jordan
peterson thomas soule and milton
friedman the leaders of the alt-right so
you know at least at least she's in good
company